welcome back to new rock stars the sun
has set and the moon is rising that's
right moon night is finally here so
chain yourself to a pole pour some sand
around the bed and grab a box of
chocolates cause it's time to talk some
moon night this is rogue theory the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
off-screen producer brandon and going
rogue with me today is the god-like
omnipotent voice in my head it's jessica
clemens hello hello hello hello oh my
god
you're always telling me what to do
jessica and i listen every time
and someone whose life would surely be
deemed worthy it's whitney van laningham
listen as long as uh daddy moon knight
deems me worthy that is all i care about
what a snack he is what a snacky
snack
and speaking of snacks a man ready to
fight anyone or anything in a museum
bathroom it's tommy bechtold hello
friends how are you i am
a person from england and i've been
hiding that fact this whole time wow i
never it's a beautiful accent tommy i
think both your american and your
british accent is perfect well i really
appreciate that latest gators
[Laughter]
stop trying to make laters gators happen
it's never gonna happen
that's so fetch all right let's get
let's get it on yeah let's get it on
we're here to talk about moon night um
and we know this series is clearly going
to explore egyptian mythology of course
as it relates to the mcu uh and these
gods are going to be interfering in the
lives of us earthly mortals but which
gods do we need to be so afraid of that
leads us to our first topic today who
who who are the missing gods okay if you
remember in the episode at the museum
stephen grant points out that the poster
celebrating the aeneid the enid however
you want to
say it the posters showcase only seven
gods when there should be nine come on
everyone knows there's nine gods
uh come on guys get your act together
you're on the museum for christmas
you're a museum and steven grant has to
um actually you like right you're just
working the gift shop dude come on yeah
it's like come on and then he and then
like his [ __ ] boss is like are you
auditioning again to be a chewa guide
and it's like yeah why not he's really
good at it why are you being an actress
he knows way more than he should yeah
like
a lot and clearly children enjoy him
he's great with kids he's cool like he
yeah i think that yeah put him front and
center plus he's a snack come on
everyone wants something
he's hot hot people are never treated
that poorly in the workplace i'm sorry
but they're just not like that woman
would not be treating oscar isaac's well
you know you know he's hot because he
has like uh insane
like psychotic break and he's still
going on a date with a very attractive
person like oh
yeah he like still can get it she's like
you know what i don't care if this guy
disappears for weeks at a time i'll have
a steak with him that sounds great i'll
have a mistake with this okay that he
disappears
i also loved that he was like oh no it's
such a problem that i have chains on my
bed no woman will want me and i'm like
stephen that is where you are wrong i
think you're you're going to get a very
a very
woman right there
[Laughter]
well well who do we think that stephen
was talking about who are these two gods
that we think are missing on the poster
you guys have some thoughts around that
yeah obviously mephisto
well i think one's got to be conscious
right like one's got to be the big k
special k
that would make a lot of sense right so
let's let's quickly recap who is part of
the iniad because there's a certain
certain set of gods who are on it so the
members of the iniad are horus osiris
tefnut shu adam isis set
jeb or geb depending on if you pronounce
it like jeff or jeff uh gaff virgif and
then nut there's literally a guy named
uh yeah and i'm pretty sure that he's
the one who's left out because disney
was like that's too dirty we're cutting
out the blood and we're cutting out any
potential testing we gotta bust that nut
back on the poster plus that nut back on
there you know yeah bust him back in
that's the traditional egyptian anyhead
right our egyptian mythology that's what
we yeah and then the ones that uh steven
says he sees on the poster for sure are
adam shu and osiris so we know that
those three are definitely on them right
even though osiris is not a traditional
any ed from our egyptian mythology in
the mcu maybe it's one of their and yet
right so is it is it just conscious and
that death goddess that uh ethan hawk
worships maybe the two of them well you
could have ahmed on there but ahmed's
not traditionally a full-blown goddess
right she's like
more of a
she works for anubis usually anubis
utilizes her to like eat the hearts the
bad hearts you gotta eat those hearts
i'm trying to think here then what makes
the most sense who's missing who because
we're playing by a different set of
rules right like this is the marvel
version of this super team maybe they're
the eternals i saw that someone tweeted
that out that those gods are all best
okay
so there could be missing eternals from
this uh uh this poster and maybe they
could show up in the show maybe maybe
whichever ones are still alive and or on
earth yeah i don't think it's anubis
because they mentioned that uh
they're missing it not only from the
poster but from like the art outside of
the
museum and anubis is everywhere in that
museum um in that store so i don't think
it's anubis uh i was really trying to
zoom and enhance on this thing on disney
plus but it didn't i was getting
confused because bass is a cat well uh
pardon me it like but like an anubis is
the dog-like figure so i was like what
i'm trying to differentiate the dog and
bass but i think it might be best
zooming back in i think it might be best
uh because of what you said brandon
holding on to the fact of like the black
panther and the heart-shaped herb and
everything that go with that i think
bass is a good figure so i think that's
what konshu or the sun king itself
doesn't want anyone to address best yet
they're like bass is a good version of
us and best best best best best best
well there's variations of spelling and
variations of pronunciation
there's sometimes it's like b-a-a-s-t
sometimes it's like yeah yes apostrophe
t
uh so yeah i think kind of bounce around
but i like that idea jessica because in
marvel comics basta is usually
represented in the indian because
obviously with the connection to wakanda
and the heart shaped herb and like raw's
heart potentially becoming the
heart-shaped herb uh that would be very
interesting i you know that's my hope is
that they try and tie in bass to the
show somehow to kind of make that
connection of like wakanda to this the
and yet and like the whole backstory
there i think that'd be a lot of fun
absolutely but i think you're also on
the right track with like kanchu being
left off because that might be why he's
so pissed right right that's why he's
using uh mark spector slash stephen
grant he's like you got to get me on
this poster i should be on the poster
i got to sell t-shirts
i would say i said uh
when
the lovely whitney was tweeting and live
tweeting during the show i i tweeted and
i was like i think it's conscious and
best and i think it's conscious because
in the comics konshu is not a good
person so i think the other gods don't
want to even remember konchu and if you
can go through these different timelines
in different universes i think they can
make a universe in which we see mark
right now and the rest of the people
don't recognize that konchu exists just
mark mark is the only person that's like
we're missing like two other gods and
they're like yeah so he's wiped out but
i think because i think how they're
really holding how arthur harrow's
really holding on to emmett and like
anubis uh i i'm just like i think
everyone's aware that these gods exist
but they're not trying to acknowledge
bass and conscious yet um and the only
people that would acknowledge them is
someone like mark who can see him and
hear him all the time i like to imagine
there's some poor graphic designer
working for the museum he keeps trying
to add kanchu and just keeps having like
a heart attack
will completely harass him and be like
you're missing two and he's like i'm not
missing two just because you work in the
shop doesn't mean i'm i don't work here
also like there's not a there's not a
seventh there's not an eighth there's
not a ninth like
i just feel like everyone takes it
doesn't exist no go keep going sorry do
you think it could potentially be like a
westworld scenario or maybe there are
nine on the poster and mark's not seeing
it yeah like the woman his boss is just
like not even looking at it to see if
he's right or wrong i think he's just
like shut up stephen so this is a longer
queue i noticed that the
i think the writer noticed that longer
queue that the writer knowledge that
like not all the main characters we see
in the comic book won't be in the series
they just didn't have time so they made
nods to them so that woman could be a
nod to the character in the comic book
but i think she's uh she's amit i think
she's the crocodile
i think she's crocodile guys and she's
making his life a living hell because in
the comic books she was his therapist
and she kept being like you can't do
this you have to stay here and she was
like and he was like no there's
something weird about there's something
off about this and it turned out that
she was actually
the goddess
emmett so i think that's her and she's
completely disregarding him as a human
being and being like no you're just
crazy you're stupid shut up yeah like
yeah feeding into his already so mean to
stephen yeah they are horrible to him
kanchu calls him a worm it's not nice
he's such a nice
also an [ __ ]
you know that elevator scene i screamed
so hard because it was so good i was
like it was so good but that that's my
theory sorry that was that's my idea
that's a good theory i liked it really
cool actually i like that a lot
i'm on board there anyone else we think
could be missing from this poster i am
wondering the other like toy that i saw
in the gift shop they had a bunch of
little
hippo toys and i looked it up and
there's a hippo goddess called towerette
and so i was like ooh i wonder if
there's gonna be any hippos someday
maybe
i don't know i'd like to see that
this is just
i hate that i know i i don't hate that i
know this my mom made me read a lot of
egyptian books as a child because i'm
black
but
i do know that they use the hippopotamus
and the crocodile as the goddess ammit
because they both like
man
and i remember i i remember being like
yeah this is why we should be afraid of
hippos so i wonder if that is also a
call back to like maybe she's not a
crocodile in this maybe she's a hippo or
maybe yeah hippo is another day an
egyptian mythology amma is a mix of like
the a lion a hippo and an alligator or
crocodile is the most like deadly things
to man in egypt in marvel comics they
they kind of add in the leopard too and
all of the spots on emmett are eyes like
it's this other like weird thing that
emma can do so a lot of animal mixing
she's a chimera you know what i mean
she's a mix of all these animals put
together um but some great theories
here's gang uh i i really hope that this
is a little clue it could just be a
weird little thing where arthur's or i'm
sorry where stephen's being annoying and
pointing out it's wrong and it doesn't
add to anything but it's got to be
something it's got to be a hint
so i'm going to hand out some rogies
whitney look at you roger i love the
idea of uh
the hippo goddess you got something
jessica
no i just thought about i was like i got
more reason why okay this is a side note
[ __ ] don't address it but the fact
that like who let arthur harrow into the
museum after night and all those people
right
he's got pants he's got
yeah well he has plants but i was like
that one of those plants could be that
woman that we all [ __ ] hate who's
actually uh
that let them through
but jessica that's project mayhem
this one i also just wanna if i can jump
into this show i would punch that woman
in the throat so hard because i'd be
like what's the point what's the point
of making his life like this why are you
right here
so mean to him for no reason you know
you don't know what i mean like she
could have it rough at home that's true
in the museum
all right whitney i'm gonna give you a
rogue point uh for your theory about the
hippo goddess being left off the poster
because i love those cute little hippos
mostly just because i want one of those
plushies and i want to buy it so i want
it to matter because i want to have
merch of it be careful museum gift shops
are dangerous museum gift shops are
dangerous
sell them at disney parks you cowards
come on jessica and i are both
i think i'm just gonna start showing up
absolutely showing up at museums they
could be they could be tommy i'm to give
you a rogue point for the idea that
conscious left off the poster i mean it
seems so good so obvious i love that
jessica i got to give you two rogue
points because i want it to be best so
bad so bad give me that best i want to
see it let's make these connections i'm
all about that bro
you could say that's the
best theory
i could say await me but i'm not going
to
i see myself out up next we're going to
talk about arthur harrow's magic
warrachees but first
right now head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com and grab the new
latest obsession shirt inspired by moon
knight it's a great shirt with a design
inspired by egyptian iconography
there's a limited supply of these bad
boys so you should grab one quick it
will also unlock the ability to have a
shout out red on an upcoming episode of
inside marvel you don't want to miss
that if you've always wanted eric or mt
to shout out your pet theory the love of
your life or your mandatory work
softball team this is your chance so get
it now at newrockstarsmerch.com
watching netflix without using
expressvpn is like buying tickets to a
taylor swift concert but only being
allowed to watch the first four songs
what a bummer and she didn't even do
your favorite one netflix has thousands
of shows but without a vpn you only get
access to a fraction of that based on
your location there are other shows and
films available in other countries and
you're missing out on them expressvpn
lets you change your online location and
control where you want netflix or other
streaming services to think you're
located a great example is rick and
morty and new rock stars we're going to
want to re-watch previous seasons ahead
of a new season coming out by switching
to australian netflix we can access
those we just open up the app select
australia tap one button to connect
refresh the page and we're off and
running we love how fast the speeds are
letting us stream in hd with zero
buffering expressvpn works with other
streaming services beside netflix
including bbc iplayer youtube and more
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting a
fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com
rogue don't forget to use my link at
expressvpn.com
rogue to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free i'm busy you're busy
we're all busy give me a break you could
save some time in your schedule and
still eat really well if you leave your
meals to factor factor makes it easy for
you to eat clean 24 7 with fresh never
frozen prepared meals that are so
delicious you won't believe they're
actually good for you i refuse to
believe it factor saves me time by
delivering chef-crafted meals to my
doorstep eliminating the hassle of
grocery shopping and meal prep not to
mention clean up there's no dishes to
wash i don't even wash dishes i usually
break them on the floor out of
frustration each factor meal arrives
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes that's even faster than ordering
in factor tackles the tough stuff so you
don't have to their registered
dietitians and expert chefs work hand in
hand to create meals with nutritious
ingredients and with more than 29 meal
options each week i'm never bored factor
even knows my preferences they offer
vegan and veggie meals keto meals low
calorie options cold pressed juices
smoothies energy bites plant-based bars
extra protein veggie sides and more to
keep me fueled and focused all day long
head to go.factor75.com
roguetheory120 and use code
roguetheory120
to get 120 off that's code
roguetheory120 at go.factor75.com
roguetheory120 for 120 off superheroes
have super powers but that does not mean
that they don't need a skin care routine
between insomnia and late night fights
there is no sleep for our boy moon night
get this man some eye cream in a
skincare routine already fifty percent
of guys suffer from issues like dark
under eye circles puffiness tired eyes
fine lines and wrinkles this is where
geology comes in they will help you make
handsome a habit geology is a nine-time
award-winning men's skincare company
recognized in men's health esquire and
ask man grooming awards
geology creates a simple and effective
skincare routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are proven to work
and formulated for daily use their
products not only help with under eye
circles but also fight acne reduce
oiliness and prevent wrinkles get on
board today by clicking the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and with a few clicks tell them
about your skin care and goals and their
team of dermatologists will design a
regimen just for you that is shipped
directly to your door it's that simple
we're big fans of geology products here
at new rockstars they're easy to use and
work great head to geology.com and take
their free skincare quiz to save up to
50 off your 30-day trial or just click
the link below that's
i e g-e-o-l-o-g-i-e
com or click the link below to save 50
off on your 30 day trial all right guys
in the first episode of moon night it
doesn't take long for steven grant and
arthur harrow to cross paths it's clear
that arthur harrow is going to be the
main villain for this series and he's no
cinderella but boy do we need to talk
about his glass slippers that leads us
to our second topic for today
what is up with the pain sandals i mean
this series begins with arthur harrell
performing a unique ritual that ends
with him putting broken glass in his
otherwise comfy leather sandals what's
the reason for this painful foot
treatment do his followers know he's
doing this do his shoes get bloody what
is his drinking glass budget let's try
and figure this out crew what is going
on with these sandals why does he have
to do it every time yeah
is it a new glass everywhere was it like
just that one time
he just keeps shuffling around until it
crumbles to like a fine powder and then
he does it again yeah
he's keeping restaurant supply companies
in business that's what i'm thinking
that's what i'm thinking it just goes to
a red robin and snatches the margarita
yes
but uh
seriously my my theory is that he has to
be in a state of constant pain to
connect to his goddess that is what
tethers him to her is he's constantly
wounded he's constantly
in peril and that allows him to have a
closer connection i think that's why
that's why i do okay okay yeah that's
why you do it yeah yeah that's right
there's a lot of history of like
in different religions you know
self-flagellation
closer to the suffering to understand
pain
to understand that stuff
uh that's one way to look at it so you
think he does it every day tommy do you
think he's gonna do this every day i do
just when he's gonna do the ritual
i think it's i think it's probably very
specific actually to when he takes the
hands of someone and judges them
and the tattoo the tattoo never lies i
think i think that i think it's all i
think it's all connected i think the
feet got to be bloody to get the tattoo
up and running you know
yeah i
agree with tommy
um i just go go further further
okay go further in we gotta go further
in i i i agree with daddy uh daddy tommy
uh so
daddy dummy
i i i think it's worth noting that like
yeah so the self-flagellation i think it
is close like this is just their ritual
of being closer to amit but i also think
that like he's being punished for his
past crimes because dr arthur
harrow did perform experiments on humans
and so and they linked it back to like
being a nazi so i think
he probably has a pass that's completely
horrendous and he's like i gave myself
fully to emmett and now i'm her like
vessel and i think i don't think she he
completely is the vessel but i do think
that's the tethering is he wasn't just
like randomly chosen he was a monster
she chose him and now he's still being a
monster taking the lives of people
through for emmett but i think it's
because he is just like he's like i i
i brought pain upon all these people
so it's only fair that i get give myself
pain but stepping on glass is not
anywhere near as close as you know
forming weird experiments on people yeah
so maybe in this so in marvel comics he
was like a nazi right jessica yeah maybe
he's like
ex hydra here he could be one of uh like
oh that's true yeah that's true he was
they just like tied his experiments to
back to auschwitz and i was like okay
and
but the mcu or not the mcu but marvel
comics love villains being nazis uh
because they love turning any bad guy
into a nazi so i think that's your
ultimate your ultimate villain right
there yeah that's your ultimate villain
it's such easy writing back in the day
of just being like just make him a nazi
just pick up a nonsense just like he's
bad uh but yeah so i think
while he was doing all those experiments
maybe he's still doing the experiments
but i doubt it i think this is now his
new found life of just like i'm no
longer going to hurt people
i'm just going to kill them through this
god that i worship
but
you know finding himself after
being bad
so tommy you brought up the idea that
like and jessica too like the he's got
his past transgressions we do know he
mentions that someone betrayed emmett
and that's what has like affected her
right there was a betrayal at some point
could he be the betrayer and this is his
penance
is working for her and punishing himself
with a broken glass
i bet it's freaking konshu and he knows
that konshu is working through mark or m
at least does or at least they do now
because of that whole like bust scene or
that car cupcake scene but i think i
think definitely she's conscious
probably did something to anubis
um it's so weird because i like anubis
in the
comics but i guess we're trying to set
him up to be a bad guy here maybe maybe
maybe not i don't know he's just
guarding the underworld you know what do
you want him to do what's his job okay
well okay so
so what if we are attaching it to i
can't remember who the writer of this
run of moon knight was but if we do
connect it to the comic book where he is
working he is literally a patient and a
psych ward and amma is the therapist
what if he got snatched out of that
world because he got snatched out of
that world and went into a different
world where he was escaping with uh
crowley and all the other people and
crowley is clearly the the gold man the
standard is clearly the gold statue so
what if they did exit that world through
anubis into a new world and amit's like
i was betrayed by conscious because
conscious helped him exceed and get out
of here and how dare you okay so i like
it
that's my theory there you go there you
go
serving it up gary's way
beautiful beautiful well and in that run
jessica wasn't akanshu and amit working
together a little bit when they were
trying to trick mark and pushing further
because they were like kind of working
together to like break mark down all the
way yeah they could that's the thing
they could still go with that but for
like just
movie and tv and entertainment purposes
they could still have that storyline and
make khan you betray her in the process
and be like i'm taking mark for myself
and it's like where are we gonna do this
together this is supposed to be a tag
thing and emma is nothing compared to
khan she or not nothing but is like
conscious much more higher than him so
it's like i can do whatever i want i
just can't be seen and that's why i have
mark doing it
yes yes you are supposed to save the
aeneid not leave it and shattered
he says i hate him deuces
wendy i gotta ask you do you think that
his followers know he's doing this glass
thing or is this just for just for daddy
is it just for him just for daddy uh no
that's actually what i was gonna say i
think that the reason he does it is
because
so
in interviews ethan hawk said that he
kind of based the character on like
david koresh the leader of the branch
davidian from waco shout out to waco i
lived there for a while
not the branch davidians though i didn't
live in the branch dividing snow but it
did live in thank goodness
i was not in a cult uh yet as far as i
know but uh i
having that
knowing that the character is based on
an actual cult leader i think that
his followers do know that he does this
and that he's using it as a
psychological manipulation tactic to get
them to
respect slash fear him as a leader
because
i mean i'm just thinking about like
i can't think of like specific examples
but like you've seen like religious
leaders like especially those like you
know like those big mega churches where
they perform like the casting out of
demons on their followers and [ __ ] like
you've seen people do things where it's
like the lord is working through me i
will walk across this bed of glass and i
won't die watch right and like i feel
like i feel like like religious leaders
the bad ones do that [ __ ] to like
convince their followers like oh god
really is working through me oh amit
really is working through him he can put
glass in his shoes and walk around and
he's still okay because of the power of
believing and nominating look at the
pain he can do yeah look at that i mean
you've got a great point there yeah
because that would scare the [ __ ] out of
me if i was watching a dude like if i
knew for a fact that like
my
i guess boss
pastor i don't know like whatever
yeah like i don't know whatever if i
knew he was just like sliding some glass
into his crocs every morning who would
be afraid of that person i would not
want to [ __ ] with that person so yeah i
think i think it's a i think it's a
manipulation tactic that he's using yeah
there's there's like you know the
walking across the hot coals right but
really yeah yeah yes yes yes yes so that
it's okay here's the
handling of snakes but they've taken all
the venom or they've cut the frames off
yes
you're right okay so you have better all
those sorts of weird little
right it could gameplay glass and he's
there i don't know no one's seeing him
do it in his hotel room but yeah
i don't know oh i think he's like this
is just fine it's stuck to me but the
fact of him taking
what we don't know if it's water or
vodka that's what i was going to ask you
is it water is a broadcast yeah it could
be like what if it's just straight
freaking like uh alcohol like rubbing
alcohol and so it's in there and he dips
his hand and it rims it and then downs
it so i was like what does the what is
the what is the little yeah yeah
like that's an actor's choice right
there i think i don't know it might be
it might be it looks
like because we all remember it it's
it's great it's a great choice it's a
great choice as an actor to do the
little like reminding of the glass it
feels great you guys are i think you'll
be able to take a break right now
you guys just keep doing this and it's
like oh that's a little it's a little
butthole pet right there i mean that's a
little butthole pet right there where's
the lie where's the lie well i got i got
one last thing to bring up here and eric
vos brought this up in his breakdown of
the episode the the the
sand becomes glass right glass is made
of sand that's been like super heated
and formed glass uh do you think there's
any connection there that like he's
trying to grind it back down into sand
or because it is made of sand maybe
these glasses come from the sahara uh
and there's pure saharan glass and he
likes to have it i don't i think he's
stealing from a hotel room but like i
don't know
is there any is there any glass sand
connection here or is that just like
uh something that the director chose as
like a
uh a connection that's interesting
that's very interesting i didn't think
about that don't i know i i didn't i i
didn't make that connection so i was
like that's i just
realistically i think it
wouldn't i think him stabbing himself in
the foot is the self-like frag
[Music]
is that the the flagellation yeah yeah
yeah there's a self-flagellation um that
he's given himself to tether himself to
emmett but
if we did want to go with boss's theory
i think that would mean that arthur
harrow is actually someone else and has
the same thing that mark has and he
could be actually a god of like
earth or something else where it's like
i need to be as close to my like the raw
material as it can be
um okay and this small village that i'm
running
uh i think that's the only way you could
aid like you could connect that point of
just being like
why else if it's sand
who else could if he needs sand he
should just go to stephen's bedroom and
scoop a little bit all right yeah
he wakes up he's like excuse me i'm just
gonna take a little bit for myself
also where where is steven getting that
sand for his bedroom it looks like so
good yeah
like really pure oh god here comes tommy
with his tatooine i hate saying it gets
everywhere
it's coming out of his freak i okay
i'm so mad about this sam thing because
i'm just like okay so he's bringing it
out of his dreams he's recognizing that
he's going into different places or he's
doing it purposefully and if he's doing
it purposefully what's the point of
doing it purposefully so that's why i'm
like i think it's coming out of what he
thinks like he's like i'm having
nightmares but in reality he's switching
personas or personalities going all over
the place and he's bringing sam back
with him and so that's why i'm like you
just stepped over the sand that is
randomly there yeah but you yeah
something's weird about it you know
something's off about it maybe you're
just not addressing it you're like no
i'm just normal british mark spector but
it's like no you're actually moon knight
[ __ ] look around
there's no cats here no sand where's the
nearest beach in london boy get your ass
to thinking get you they don't got that
nice sand at london beaches i can tell
you no no no british beaches
they have to sell sand for like
children's sandboxes though somewhere
yeah yeah he could be getting him he's
just like taking the same from
the past
like a park oh a pet store like the nice
sand for your geckos or whatever for
your savannah monitors
at the pet store does seem to kind of
hate him so maybe everyone hates him for
some reason
i know because he comes in the hospital
and just doesn't recognize that he just
screamed at her about all right you know
and then comes back as the audacity i
think every pet store owner knows the
crazy fish guy and they hate dealing
with them plus the profit margin on a
goldfish is so low you're not making any
money selling goldfish one goldfish one
goldfish how much could it cost ten
dollars
for these damn goldfish
cat stop uh well guys i love i love all
these theories i think we've got some
good stuff going here on the sandals i
hope they they really answer all of our
questions i hope two full episodes are
devoted just to the samples on this show
absolutely
i think it'll be great and one episode
of sandals resort
oh it's brought to you by sandals i love
it
makes it so that you have a comfortable
experience oh i like that at the end
maybe he is dr scholes maybe that's one
of his own personalities what a twist
he was like i was just giving people
jealous
shoes in auschwitz wasn't doing anything
else crazy yeah oh my god
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
you you you deserve to live and to have
comfortable and to have comfortable
issues
yeah yeah yeah i will get rid of your
bunions i'm going to give each of you
two rogue points
and helping us dive into the harachi
question uh i can't wait to learn more
about it uh and i hope we do get an
answer on it but it's time for our rogue
question
are you ready for the rogue question
gang yes
row
row so during a recent curtain call for
a performance of the music man on
broadway huge i love the music man hugh
jackman was handed some foam wolverine
uh claws and gave the audience a classic
wolverine pose really got him going uh
so here's the road question what musical
would you like to see the character
wolverine star in so take your favorite
musical
swap someone out and put in wolverine oh
you want to see that music man can you
hear him in the music man we got trouble
off right
yeah oh yeah
you got trouble in river city now
[ __ ]
that's not my choice but that would be
so funny
he's going to turn the 76 trombones into
142 trombones oh
[ __ ] that's kind of at half basically
that's fast math
that's that's fast fast best math
152 ah not fast not good math that's
what it was i think i'd like to see hugh
jackman as wolverine in annie as the
titular character
he's annie he's annie he's an orphan
you're never fully dressed without a
smile
just cutting smiles on people instead of
kisses we get claws
we get sneaks yeah
absolutely i would definitely see that
it would it would improve annie 100
tommy i guarantee it again it really
would it would be the first what about
you i ever saw annie that way i think
that he should be the next
to star in dear evan hansen but
they should just say that he's a high
school student yes
wolverine's a high school student he's
got a does he have the cast i mean he
can heal pretty yeah pretty well yeah
the secret is that the claws are
underneath the castle
and nobody knows and that's how he gets
i think
i like it the big number right before uh
intermission is him bursting through the
cast with the claws
i don't need this exactly i'm gonna be
waving through the window now but
jess do you want to go with music man or
do you have another one no okay so i
have two oh
two i don't know if that's allowed
well i'm thinking of logan i'm thinking
of logan version of wolverine's older
sadder drunk
wolverine and i want him and stomp
because i think he needs to get deep
into his feelings with
but if it wasn't if it wasn't stomp i
think he could easily be typecasted in
cats
logan you are the jellicle choice
yeah
i mean that puts a whole new spin on
memories right because he doesn't have
his memories right he's like [ __ ] he's
longing for his own memories yes
oh man oh i love all these guys i love a
broadway question that's why i put it in
there and i think you all had great
answers yes uh
uh
uh if i had to pick a favorite uh
i mean i love the idea of of seeing uh
wolverine as little orphan annie yeah
i'm going to give you the rogue point
for that one uh but that leaves us with
a tie
today oh wow jessica and tommy are both
our winners
[Music]
should have
there's not enough singing for me and
stomp jessica i need to see the songs i
like prism i like beats i like beats
oh they all got rhythm they all got
rhythm yeah
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our guests so much
jessica clemens whitney van laningham
and tommy beck told support our channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you've got some thoughts on on
our rogue theories or have some rogue
theories of your own you can share them
on our discord if you're over 18 click
the link for the new rockstars discord
server in the description below and come
join the conversation follow me at grin
and barrack follow new rockstars on all
social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel here on
youtube that's why i said it three times
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you